hey guys this is vadim with max tech and
we finally got in our logitech folio
touch keyboard case with the trackpad
the one that everybody's been waiting
for and right next to it i have the
magic keyboard case right here so in
this video we're going to be doing a
comparison comparing everything from the
keyboards the track pads the design the
feel the weight the thickness basically
everything between these two to find out
if it's worth spending the extra money
because the folio touch costs 160
dollars compared to three hundred
dollars now that is a massive difference
in price so let's see
i'm going to unplug this set this aside
and let's
unbox this
all right so
here we go this is
a very thick case let me tell you that
get rid of that all right so one thing
this flap wasn't really visible on the
product images they kind of chose to
hide it but
i don't really mind opening this up we
can see that we have our layout so this
bottom keyboard portion feels basically
identical to the combo touch for the
ipad and for the ipad air i kind of feel
like literally nothing is unchanged on
this bottom portion but right here where
it connects it's actually permanently
attached because the smart connector
location of course on the ipad is on the
back right here so we have our little
pogo connectors and of course we have
the speaker cutouts on both sides and
yeah there you go we have our
2020 ipad pro square camera bump right
there so what i'm going to do first i'm
going to take off the ipad off the magic
keyboard and let's just compare these
two without the ipad inside so
side by side
you guys can tell that the difference in
thickness is massive for just the case
by itself like
that is insane like when you look at the
magic keyboard
it definitely looks really nice compared
to this guy now as far as the weight
everybody complains about the weight of
the magic keyboard case but right here
feeling them in my hands i actually
think the logitech weighs quite a bit
more than the magic keyboard of course
look how bulky it is now what i'm going
to do next is compare the ease of
basically placing the ipad in the case
so
got the 2020 ipad pro right here
just like that it's on nice and simple
and let's grab the 2018 model
looks like you kind of slide it
in the bottom half
remove this flap and just push it in as
far as i know that should be it sweet so
that was pretty simple now comparing the
hinge
so this hinge has a little bottom flap
just like on the combo touch
basically you just adjust it like this
and the nice thing is that
you have a lot of angle adjustability i
don't know if you guys can see that
right there but
a lot of angle adjustability so you can
lay it down like that but you can't
really make it face down like that where
if you look here you could actually make
the magic keyboard face down this way
you can't do that on the logitech now of
course on the magic keyboard you just
use
you could do it with one hand better to
hold but you just kind of
adjust it like that and as far as the
angle definitely you can have a much
bigger angle adjustability on the
logitech of course a major perk of the
magic keyboard is you could simply lift
off the ipad pro
put it back on like that to get this
thing out it's going to be a pain
compared to the magic keyboard like you
got to pull this off and
yeah it's not going to be fun now the
biggest perk for the logitech folio
touch is you could actually grab the
keyboard and just flip it over like that
boom you have
media viewing mode youtube movies
whatever just just like that it's
perfect you can't do that with the magic
keyboard case at all you have to lift
the ipad off to be able to use it like
that and if you fold down the flap there
you go you'll be able to use the apple
pencil so this is gonna be huge for
anybody doing drawing or note taking
it's definitely a big perk for the
logitech however if you have a very
small desk the logitech has to have this
flap hanging out and acting as a
kickstand with a magic keyboard case you
don't have to have that you could
literally have it up against the edge of
the desk and you'll be totally fine with
that you can't do that with the logitech
so that's a perk for the magic keyboard
before we move any further i want to
close these down and just compare the
overall thickness with the keyboard
cases so i've got them side to side here
and you can easily tell how much thicker
the logitech folio touch is especially
because of the added kickstand and the
extra thickness of the keyboard portion
and basically all around much thicker
than the magic keyboard case but with
the magic keyboard case the sides and
basically all around of the ipad are
exposed compared to the logitech folio
touch where basically
everything's wrapped around and like you
got a good thick
bumper here all the way around so if you
drop
your ipad pro with the logitech folio
touch
i don't think anything's gonna happen to
it honestly like this is gonna protect
it very well
whereas with the magic keyboard case
there's a very good chance that you're
going to scuff up the sides of your
metal ipad pro now before i get into
comparing the materials between these
two i want to mention that we have our
premium apple product t-shirt design
right below in our merch shelf all right
so the magic keyboard case has this
rubbery texture where like i'm rubbing
my finger against and there's a lot of
resistance so if it's on a desk like the
whole desk is moving when i'm shaking
this compared to the logitech like it
slides around very easily because this
is like a
kind of like a plasticky
almost like fiber feeling material it's
actually kind of nice almost like denim
so i really like this material and i
think
in terms of the finish the logitech is
going to last a lot longer without
getting scuffed up because i already
have like this little scuff i don't know
how i got it on the magic keyboard case
so you might see little
lines here little scratches so that's
already from not that much use and you
see a little bit of shiny spots so the
finish is definitely not going to last
very long it's going to change over time
compared to logitech this is very solid
and it feels pretty good too now one of
the downsides i'm seeing with the
logitech folio touch is that the buttons
are kind of hard to press
because you have the bumper
around the buttons you really have to
push quite a bit harder to hit these
buttons
compared to the magic keyboard case of
course they're fully exposed very nice
and clicky obviously so
that's one difference now as far as how
easy they are to open
let's test out the logitech kind of put
it up on its hinge
then you pull the flap back the
kickstand and there you go you're good
to go
with the magic keyboard case you
basically place it on the hinge and you
drop the keyboard portion down so
definitely more convenient with the
magic keyboard case i'd say one thing i
really like about the magic keyboard
case is that because of this unique
floating hinge design where the ipad is
kind of lifted up it's easier to go from
typing to touching the display compared
to with the logitech you kind of have to
i guess put your fingers back further to
access the display you almost have to
like stretch your hand out further
compared to this it's a little bit more
convenient on the magic keyboard now i
do like how logitech dealt with the
apple pencil
basically you just grab your apple
pencil you have this cut out
and there you go
it starts recharging and you just fold
the flap over
when it's not in use and i'd say that
it's definitely the
the more safe option
and it's kind of funny though i've
flipped this flap over and this is kind
of like sideways
it's not perfectly flat for some reason
but this is definitely the more safe
option if you don't want to lose your
apple pencil because it's it's holding
it there compared to with the magic
keyboard if anything happens if anything
knocks it off you could very easily lose
it as far as lap ability i think the
magic keyboard case is going to win
because you don't have to deal with
having this kickstand on your lap and it
extends further out so it's not going to
be very convenient the magic keyboard
case basically it's holding all the
weight off of the base of the keyboard
so this is definitely the better option
for lapability now i want to move into
the keyboards and the trackpads now
there's one reason why
these two keyboard cases are the best on
the market for the ipad pro and that is
the smart connector basically every
other keyboard case does not have access
to it it's only apple and logitech that
has access and i think this is the only
one for the new ipad pro now the major
advantage is that the keyboard and the
trackpad is hardwired to the ipad pro so
when you're typing you get no lag no
bluetooth issues no bluetooth connecting
as soon as you put the case on it's
instantly connected and everything works
from the keyboard to the trackpad and
it's a perfect experience no lag
incredibly smooth that's the major
benefit with the smart connector and
that's why i will always recommend one
of these two over the bridge pro plus
which uses bluetooth and it also
requires
batteries being built into it that you
do need to recharge with these you don't
need any of that now let's get into
comparing the keyboards so as far as the
typing this feels kind of like a
traditional
chiclet keys they actually feel pretty
nice
but
i personally really like the keyboard on
the magic keyboard case
it has more i guess feedback more click
to it compared to a sort of dull feeling
on the logitech so as far as the keys
themselves i'm definitely going to give
it to the magic keyboard case the major
benefit for the logitech folio touch is
that it actually gets a top row of
function keys which you do not get on
the magic keyboard case i think that's
the main reason why people choose not to
get it so let's quickly go through that
you have the
escape key right there in the corner
you have
brightness keys just like that you have
your on-screen keyboard you have your
safari spotlight search
just like that
and you have backlit key controls now
for some reason i don't know why they're
not working
it's really weird but i actually went
into
let me show you the logitech control app
and i don't have any controls for that
for some reason and it says i am up to
date
so
i'm really not sure why it's not working
and i just took out the keyboard case
put it back in just to double check it's
still not working so i don't know what's
going on with that
but moving on we have our media keys we
have um
go back a track you gotta skip forward
you have pause play you have your
volume keys this is very very convenient
compared to the magic keyboard you kind
of go up there into the control center
and you can kind of control everything
just like that so based on two things
the function keys and the price this
logitech is a killer deal especially
since you get the smart connector
instead of bluetooth now as far as that
backlighting that i previously mentioned
it works perfectly on the magic keyboard
case it's automatic basically when it
becomes dark in your room the back
lighting turns on and it gets brighter
so you basically never have to touch any
backlighting controls it just works
automatically and i find that it's
always at the perfect level which is
awesome now i want to move down to the
track pads and this is where there is a
pretty significant difference first of
all
the trackpad on the logitech looks
bigger so if i
put them side by side you can see that
the surface area of the magic keyboard's
trackpad is actually smaller it is a
little bit wider
but it's significantly thinner now you
might be asking how is the trackpad
slimmer on the magic keyboard if there's
no top row of function keys well
because of this floating design apple
couldn't put
extra keys up here near the top because
then you'd be reaching your fingers
under the ipad pro and it just wouldn't
be very convenient so that's why and if
you look at the
x-ray of the magic keyboard you'll see
that there's quite a bit of wiring and
there's a circuit board there and it
actually is there to control a very
important feature that i'm gonna get
into in just a moment now back to the
track pads let's compare the feel now
the biggest downside for the logitech is
that it uses a diving board design which
means it's connected here at the top of
the trackpad so
if you try to click it up here you
literally can't i'm like pushing down
pretty hard and it's not clicking now as
you go down further now you can start to
click
and at the very bottom it's very very
easy to click now it's totally different
on the magic keyboard because apple
designed
a really unique design you guys can see
right here that they have this weird
floating design of the track pad where
anywhere that you press down
any corner at the top bottom
middle it feels the same you have an
even clicking feel just like you get
with the macbooks as far as how they
feel they both use a little glass panel
so they both feel incredibly smooth and
swiping left and right it's actually not
perfect on the logitech sometimes it
skips over i'm not sure why it does that
let's test the magic keyboard
alright so the magic keyboard i don't
know why or how but every swipe on the
home screen
is registering
perfectly
now i just did it on the logitech and
it's skipping it skips look at that just
skipped two pages even though it feels
nice in the
transitions between the home screens are
pretty smooth it does sometimes skip a
page which is not supposed to do now i'd
say it's definitely much better than the
bridge pro plus because if you've seen
that review it is just totally messed up
i wouldn't recommend that trackpad
experience to anybody and the worst part
about that keyboard case was that when
you're scrolling like on a website
facebook whatever it would be very
choppy it wouldn't be smooth now the
benefit with the logitech is that it's
perfectly smooth
perfectly smooth scrolling you can
adjust the speed you can scroll slowly
quickly
it's really nice
because logitech is working closely with
apple to get the apis and they're using
the smart connector so you get a really
really nice experience and of course
the magic keyboard you get the same same
thing and even though this trackpad is
not as tall i find that it's still
perfect i don't find myself hitting the
limits and
having it mess with my experience
scrolling now probably the number one
benefit for both of these keyboard cases
is support for three finger gestures so
you can swipe left and right
to switch between
apps or pages
so it works
on both of them and i guess sometimes it
doesn't work perfectly
i think it definitely works a little bit
better on the magic keyboard case
so three fingers to swipe up let me try
that there you go
to hit the home screen
and you can swipe between apps
just like that
and you could also pinch to zoom into
photos on both of these
which is nice which you don't get on
other keyboard cases like the bridge pro
plus so based on all of that the
trackpad on the magic keyboard case is
definitely the winner especially for
that better clicking feel even clicking
all the way around compared to the
diving board design but it this is
definitely a lot better than other track
pads now there is one final feature with
the magic keyboard case that is totally
unique i've never seen this before on
any other keyboard case and let's get
right into it i have my charging cable
right here so with the logitech you
simply
plug it in there you go you're charging
but with the magic keyboard case you
could either plug it in
in the ipad pro itself or
in the hinge you actually get a built-in
let me lift this up for you guys
built-in power connector in the hinge
now that is why i think apple
had to be very conservative with the
keyboard not adding the top row function
keys because they actually have
a motherboard that has to handle the
power going in through the hinge and
connecting through the smart connector
and powering and charging
the ipad pro now what i really like
about this is that the power cable is
kind of out of the way it's back behind
the ipad pro it's kind of hidden so it
doesn't really get in your way like it
would be if it's plugged straight into
the ipad pro now the biggest benefit is
that while you have your charging cable
charging your ipad pro you can actually
connect a storage drive whatever you
want to connect into the ipad pro
right into its original port and you
could be charging and using storage at
the same time which is totally unique
and to some people
this feature alone is worth the extra
price over the logitech alright so after
testing and comparing all those things i
think i'm ready to give my purchasing
recommendation for you guys now for a
lot of you guys the price is going to be
the deciding factor obviously 160 over
300 a lot of people are just gonna go
for the logitech just because of that
price and the fact that you get a really
good experience with that smart
connector and of course you get a couple
of things that you just can't get with
the magic keyboard first of all the top
row of function keys which is very
important to a lot of people and you get
the
side protection of the ipad pro so that
matters a lot and if that matters to you
that's probably the better choice just
to go with the logitech now what if you
could actually go either way and price
isn't that big of a deal for you and
you're just trying to figure out which
one you should buy well the magic
keyboard has a lot of advantages over
the logitech like first of all it is
incredibly solid this keyboard portion
super solid like there's no give at all
the hinge is just
i mean this is a perfect hinge just the
way it snaps
excellent compared to the logitech where
like you have this flap in the back it's
not really
that good for lap ability for using on
your lap this keyboard section
it's kind of flimsy and just not as good
build quality with the logitech the
keyboard is better the trackpad is much
much better on the magic keyboard case
the swiping the scrolling the gestures
work better on the magic keyboard case
even though the logitech also has the
smart connector the magic keyboard is
lighter it's definitely thinner it's
more portable it's more convenient but
i'd say one of the more important things
with the magic keyboard is the way it
makes you feel having this unique
floating design with the ipad being up
here and just being able to lift the
ipad off and use it for drawing or for
whatever in vertical mode and then
putting it back on this is just a very
modern feeling keyboard case compared to
the logitech
it basically looks like every other
keyboard case that's out there of course
you have the keyboard in the trackpad
but the way it feels is basically like a
legacy device yes it does give you
excellent protection of your ipad pro
but when it's closed like this
your modern awesome feeling ipad pro
just gets covered up by this old legacy
style
keyboard case and that premium feel kind
of goes away compared to with the magic
keyboard you have your whole ipad pro
exposed which is of course dangerous but
if you're the kind of person that likes
to have a naked iphone no case you just
like the premium feel you're definitely
going to like the magic keyboard case
many many times better than the logitech
and i'd say for professional users just
having the extra usbc port that allows
you to charge while you're plugging in
your hard drives your flash drives
whatever doing your work if you're doing
video editing photo editing that feature
alone is a huge hit for anybody doing
productivity work especially if we do
actually get final cut pro and other
apps from the mac coming to the ipad now
if you're the type of person that's more
budget minded of course 160 bucks that's
a much better deal than the magic
keyboard and you get the protection all
the way around you have the little flap
for the apple pencil so it doesn't get
lost so if you're the type of person
that likes to go on amazon and order a
nice bulky safe case for your iphone
you're definitely the type of person who
is going to prefer the logitech
especially since you're saving all that
money but if you want to have the best
experience and the best feel i
definitely recommend the magic keyboard
case because using it it just makes you
feel so much better i can't really
explain it but it feels like a premium
high quality macbook when you're using
this it's just so solid everything works
great the hinge everything
it just feels so different when you're
using the magic keyboard case compared
to the logitech now if that's something
that's very important to you then i
would definitely recommend spending the
extra cash on the magic keyboard case so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
this is vadim with maxtec and if you
decide to buy either of these two
keyboard cases i'm going to have links
down in the description below to the
best deals on these and if you want to
check out our magic keyboard review you
can find it right up there and
definitely check out our new apple
product merch thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]